well guys we just saw Iron Man 3 for the
second time we went to a drive-in
theater for her suggestion it was kind
of a refresher course for us so we could
get our thoughts straight on Iron Man 3
because we saw it the screen together
and you know it's one of those movies
where you can't really you just can't
review it really without saying certain
things that are spoiler if ik you know
what I mean yeah definitely especially
with this one it was like but this wait
no I can't know by the way if you don't
know this is my lovely fiancee her name
is Sam before we get into the spoiler
points just really quick they know how I
feel about it
how did you feel overall about the film
there in your enjoyment level I really
enjoyed it other than the kind of
butchering of one of my favorite
characters of the comics I had a
love-hate relationship for the mandrian
and to see one of my favorite characters
kind of butchered
yeah that's understandable and that's
one of the things I said in my review
was that hardcore fans of the Iron Man
comics which I admit I'm not well versed
in the Iron Man comics at all will
probably be disappointed with the
treatment of the Mandarin because from
what I understand he's kind of like the
Joker to bat me and he's like he's like
Iron Man's mean darkest wanna I'm sayin
if you haven't read the comics you
really should pick up the comics and go
oh man there's so much more to Tony
Stark's character than just genius
billionaire playboy what would I have
the press she told me a lot about the
comics but see that overall I enjoyed
the film I found a lot of enjoyment to
it I liked that it was a little
different you know it wasn't like Iron
Man 2 is much better than 2 I think we
both agreed I agree gave Tony Stark's
character a lot more depth a lot more
reason to actually like him I feel like
it actually made him more of a person he
was just a brain who was traumatized him
built the suit the first two movies kind
of jumped through some pretty crucial
character building rings I think and
that you kind of catch it back up in
with the third one first one it doesn't
really bring in anything that he's a
genius too much of them he built the arc
reactor built the suit but I mean that
shows some genius but not nearly the
level that is showed with his ingenuity
and a third one yeah that's one of the
things I really liked about the third
one was that a lot of his technology
was taken away from him and he was kind
of forced to improvise losing all of his
house his lab everything and he was kind
of for it was kind of like Dark Knight
Rises where Bruce loses all of his money
and he's forced to try to figure out how
to beat Batman again and this way he has
to learn how to be Iron Man without all
of his resources and I kind of like that
about it even says it at the end you can
take my toys you can take my truck
tricks but I'm still iron exactly that
is such a crucial point of this films
that he is still iron me on despite
everything that has happened in the
smell and people saying oh what happened
in New York was so bad and him with his
anxiety attacks I'm quite a foul child
being upset that he's not talking to her
about it but then like when they're
trying to be together a little bit in
sleep in the same bed she freaks out
because he has a nightmare and I felt
that was a little bit I don't know
poorly played out like she didn't
understand that he had a nightmare and
freaked out she was a little she was
being a little prissy yeah it was a
little it was more than just a little
bitchy I mean if you were having a
nightmare and something traumatizing had
just happened to you I don't really
think the love of my life should react
like that yet I mean I go we'll remember
this we'll remember this yeah keep it in
mind ever have a nightmare and I send my
Iron Man suit to attack you so
consciously don't get mad okay it was a
bitchy especially with her kind of like
swooning over the villain even again II
love it
that's like it was literally swooning at
the sight of this guy and listening to
all that good-looking in my opinion
let's talk a little bit about the
villains in this movie because that's
really what everyone is up in arms about
obviously Allan's Oh obviously the
trailer made it seem like the mandarins
gonna be the main villain Ben Kingsley
is portraying him he's a very a very
very renowned actor he's actually really
good I mean yeah got played Gandhi he
want I think won the Oscar for playing
Gandhi I mean playing a drunkard idiot
guy and actually nailing it not looking
like a buffoon doing it is probably
pretty hard that is the one thing
because despite the fact that I was like
really that's the twist that's kind of
that's kind of a cop-out I laughed like
I was kind of laughing it was kind of
funny when iron man's like prompts to
help you get off drugs
did give me more
kind of funny a character was actually
kind of very complex with its actual own
backstory yeah that you don't even
really get with the central point
villain of this initially you get the
blur with the rooftop and you're like
okay well what other than that made him
so evil evil I mean what happened to
make him cripple what happened to make
him so bitter at the world the needs to
find these people in him like the
motivation was a little lacking yeah I
mean but with the other guy with the
actor you can kind of see where he was
in a bad spot got in some drugs got
pumped up with the wrong crowd me I
don't know it just it didn't seem like
they put all that much thought into the
main villain that's one of the weird
things about this movie because it is so
different from the other Iron Man movies
and from the Avengers and obviously a
lot of fans are up in arms about the toy
if you like if you're watching Dark
Knight Rises and halfway through veins
in the football stadiums like we're a
boy you know what fuck it I'm an actor
and this is all a big show see you later
maybe you sleep I guess actually it
really would be like the Joker saying oh
I'm just being paid to do this well the
big guys are doing all the actual
underground work
I'm just the distraction this is my
figurehead and everything behind me is
more what you should worrying about and
I just had to separate my love of the
comics from the movie to actually enjoy
the movie as a standalone like watching
the movies in sequence Ironman one
Ironman two Avengers two Iron Man 3
alright not too bad I really do wish
though that maybe the ending was a
little bit more open-ended a little less
rushed I agree it went from them leaving
the docks to him being on an operating
table to necklace yeah you're right that
was one of my other problems with the
movie is I couldn't spoil it but in my
review I said there were certain things
in Iron Man 3 that seemed like they were
way too convenient they were huge plot
points and other films they sort of just
let happen and one of them was the
shrapnel inside him in the arc reactor
keeping it from coming to his heart now
they showed that they were using some
sort of magnetism to pull it out of him
but the thing is I just that was such a
huge plot point in the other films I
would have liked more time to show what
exactly that was all about
I mean the procedure a little bit more
in depth with that all I'm saying is it
was such a big plot point yeah yeah they
should have like maybe did more than
just one little shot where whoa I guess
he's opening that there was a section in
the middle where like there wasn't too
much action it was just kind of Tony
doing his thing but the reason I like
that is because the whole theme kind of
of the movie is that you can take away
the parts you can take away the pieces
but he's still iron man and he proved
that a lot in this movie because he
really actually isn't in this suit that
much it's a lot of it is just Tony a lot
of destroyed the arts hanging around a
lot of it is just start being clever and
being and using his ingenuity to get out
of situations and I like that because it
was yeah I like when a hero who has a
lot of resources that we just don't have
it we can't relate to you like being a
billionaire has that taken away from him
it proves you can still be a hero like
in Dark Knight Rises it's kind of nice
and refreshing to see a hero not be so
over-the-top overblown superficial right
I know I enjoyed that little bit of a
spin but you messed with a central point
character like the Mandarin but see
that's the thing that everyone keeps
coming back to is wow they did that and
there's two things I can say about that
see when I was watching the movie I was
like why aren't they really it's okay
I was like why aren't they really
building up the Mandarin why are they
just showing these little 2 second
over-the-top newsreels you're not
getting anything in the Mandarin and
then when you see the shot of him coming
in and guy Pearce's like no one look him
in the eye unless you want to get shot
in retrospect that was probably him
saying this guy's a method actor he
doesn't want anyone to look him in the
eye when he acts yeah or I will shoot
you because I'm actually the Mandarin
I'm the main bag yeah but uh if I fart
real quick I love you um no the thing is
when you when you take that and you
realize that they didn't really build up
that character it kind of made sense to
me when they revealed that he wasn't the
villain because they didn't build him up
at all and so I didn't feel as
disappointed but I can see that someone
who like read every Iron Man comic from
issue one who was like just who has
literally the Mandarin fan Kingsley
poster on their wall and went home and
looked at the Ben Kingsley poster and
was like wow that poster is coming down
like I can see that guy being really
pissed you know what I mean
like you so I understand the comic
perspective but I also understand that
from a movie perspective it was kind of
interesting separate the two role right
kind of make its own arc then I can kind
of see it aldrich killian his character
I mean you have the build up for him at
the beginning where you see him standing
on the roof and Tony kind of blowing him
off and Tony kind of feeling like he
kind of Craven his own enemy right which
he kind of did he slept with the girl
blew off the guy I don't get why the guy
got so upset by being blown up when I
mean for God's sake he looked crazy yeah
he looked crazy and modem is a little
little weak it's his crazy hair the
gnarly teeth and the kit bent over cave
you don't present yourself that way
right he was an idiot and you know he
turned into a maniac
he drew a turn into a meeting I could
miss maniac when immediate unless the
girl he slept with and blew off and
solved the formula on the back of the
card coming back to bite him in the ass
of her getting killed because he's
trying to protect her and turn it back
into a good person again kind of a
little little shade and a little
underdeveloped that's what I said in my
review and I couldn't again say a lot of
really shade things in this there were I
mentioned in my review all the little
cronies the little cohorts of the
villain like the side people like
Rebecca Hall the woman well they all
just kind of came together apparently
and wanted to be really evil and murder
people but they were kind of
underdeveloped the main white the white
guy the main bald guy who follows around
everywhere I didn't care for him like he
I don't know what he what was his name
yeah I mean you see him more than you
see Aldridge yeah the problem I'm having
with like all these people that he's
taken we're all former soldiers who
their biggest thing was their right to
protect their country and yes I got
injured in Lee a stay lost a limb or had
they had some help defect because they
got into this war and you know they're a
chance terrorists
yeah another terrorist I mean you're all
real you're offering them a chance to
have their body part again and people
will jump at that what now I'm gonna go
blow people up at the end like he sends
like 30 to 40 of his suits to come back
okay
see this is why she's here you were very
helpful well there's Mark 7 in the
Avengers which we already knows if you
actually look at the cases then pretty
sure there were seven cases lined up
from the mark one are the landmark seven
and then you have 42 the prodigal child
as Tony calls him and then you have
simple mathematical elimination you take
42 minus 7 he got 35 suits of armor and
then he manages to blow every single one
of them up in various stages hey Sam I
know so this is the geeky side Mincy
marry me hmm
needs to be geekier you need to be eat
here anyway
at the end of Iron Man 3 he's 35 suits
come and a friend of mine was like you
know why didn't he just call them
throughout the whole friggin movie to
help him and then I realized there was
like this one little 2 second line that
I missed where Jarvis was like so the
debris has been cleared from the whole
of the thing or whatever I'm like ok so
the debris was trapping it got it but I
really liked that finale that was a
really great finale because the other
finales of Iron Man 1 & 2 I felt were a
little weak like there wasn't like a big
fight scene there were like especially
to like freakin whiplash blows up and
then a garden somewhere like how Pepper
Potts turned into the badass bitch out
of it absolutely freaking nowhere I mean
yeah she got injected by this sirum shit
but really she's still Pepper Potts I
mean yes she's I like that for other
reasons if you say it's because of the
sports bra I like sports bra she killed
the guy I mean it just didn't seem like
her type of character unless the serum
turned something in her head weird
should make more I think that's kind of
is what happened because they never I
mean they did sort of like after she
punched him she was like whoa whoa and
she was like that was really violent
like she kind of came out of it yeah
like it was sort of control never
explained button more endemic but that's
what I meant about the ending I never
signed anything there was like a big
kind of mishmash of a perfect wrap a
little bow it feels kind of like amazing
spider-man where they chopped out of
maybe a few too many scenes to make it
fit in a certain time parameter it feels
like there's I feel like when we get the
DVD there's going to be a lot of
possible deleted scenes that should have
been it are supposed to explain things
because it
you just get this feeling like in a
couple spots where there's like man I
wish they would have explained this more
MORE something is missing
by the way clear if you guys pick up the
amazing spider-man blu-ray or DVD and
watch the deleted scenes you will
actually think or on YouTube you will
actually just like that movie I'm not
even kidding yeah I liked it my song I
saw Elia scenes in our ladies a play
different movie and it better and I
won't you know what I did I actually I
actually went back and I watched The
Amazing Spiderman and stopped it where
all those though he scenes were supposed
to be and I'm like you did that yes I
told your McGee it's fine and I put this
deleted scenes back in I'm just like oh
this is such a better movie it really
was right from being probably a B to
like in at least an egg okay with Iron
Man 3 I still enjoyed the film despite
that kind of ludicrous twist that that
would you know hurt a lot of comic fans
and the way they felt by that character
I still enjoyed the film it was very
funny Robert Downey jr. was great in it
as always he's good in everything really
I actually kind of think when is
Paltrow's characters just a tad what we
get this one I do you think maybe she
should have died no I don't think she
should have died I think she just was
kind of in the character development
process they made it so much Tony Tony
Tony Tony Tony but then you got the
feeling
Gweneth part was just damsel in distress
yeah a little bit and you're just like
and then she just randomly turns into
his badass care yeah I feel I mean she's
she got the little bit of segments in
the beginning and then she got that big
segment at the end and everything else
in between there's like very little
blooper reel of her in a hotel room than
her being poor that's true that hotel
room thing there's certain things in the
movie that felt out of place a little
tonally weird shifts but I enjoyed the
film I liked it more than - not as much
as one or the other I kind of liked what
they did to war machine turning into
iron patriot just a little bit I liked
Don Cheadle more on this for sure that
yeah she certainly brought his character
back and who knows maybe from the way
they played it they might put iron
patriot in Avengers G that would be
pretty awesome I think that'd be pretty
cool kind of couches and the Avengers
oh boy no no black widow is the only one
for me and you that's a great film a
little underdeveloped a little bit a lot
of a little bit of missing segments just
because of how the Avengers played an
Iron Man one plate I'm writing here we
conclude Iron Man 2 and thought process
whatsoever smart girl
I really am hoping that they might do
something more with it the vendors to
with you vendors to which I'm
interesting how they're gonna get into
that since he sort of is like you know
I'm just gonna just a distraction you
know I don't say that just tone it down
that he's gonna tone it down I might
walk the Machine blew up all the things
less distractions listen it'll have to
be something that threatens her and the
world and hand it where she can actually
be like go do it kind of like how MJ's
like go Tiger at the end of spider-man 2
he'll find a way to having a little tie
in at the end the Bruce Banner Inge yeah
which is interesting because like my
friend was like you know that means that
that Robert Downey is narrating the
movie to Bruce Banner yeah
which is kind of cool I like that I gave
it a B+ originally I'm gonna stand by my
grade what would you give it an 11th
grade B+ is pretty fair maybe NRA - but
I mean the only reason I would say a
minus over B+ is because it had a lot of
maybe more sleuth warp to it lucky horse
of a spy thriller work yeah even the end
credits music was sort of spying I have
to say though don't waste your money on
the 3d not worth it but overall we
enjoyed Iron Man 3 appreciate you guys
watching this video with us obviously
since this is a giant spoiler filled
video what are your thoughts on Iron Man
3 the spoilers to twist everything down
below and as always thanks for watching
thank you for being in the video and
maybe one manage steel comes out we'll
do another one you want chocolate yeah
this is a one track woman one track mind
she's everywhere we'll get some
chocolate you want to you want to do a
Man of Steel spoiler thing with me
alright we'll do that right now in June
thanks as always for watching guys me
and my little wonder
an outfit I would enjoy this wait no
actually I'm Supergirl out the two maybe
not actually a friend wouldn't why don't
I know about this as Iron Man said in
this movie you should wear that more at
home another geek trunk oh please if I
go to Paltrow's ABS I would so dress
like that at home a little bit more
often very good now if you had Chris
Evans body